le passé
comme chaque jour sada animateurs et
éducateurs de la maison de la jeunesse
et de la réussite de carrières sous
poissy répond aux interrogations du
public les bénéficiaires de ce lieu ce
sont les jeunes aides à la formation
parcours vers l'autonomie trois
animateurs et une coordinatrice à nîmes
de l'information et de l'écouté nous
aime beaucoup cambiasso prochaine sont
leurs vies aussi perso sorti sur la vie
perso quand ils ont des problèmes dans
leur famille conclut avec leurs parents
comment on peut les aider on nous
oriente il a contraint des 16-25 dans
tout ce qui est cv lettre de motivation
accompagnement aussi deux fois d'aller
demander de logements d accompagner un
peu on les oriente surtout aussi les
domaines de la caf mais voilà en tous
lieux d'information mais aussi lieux de
détente avec des activités organisées
inauguré en septembre 2021 cette maison
a pris place dans les anciens locaux de
la bibliothèque municipale
plus de 500 jeunes ont déjà été
accompagné le 27 janvier la structure a
été labellisé cité de la jeunesse par la
ministre de la ville c'est une démarche
qui vient reconnaît tout un engagement
des professionnels du secteur et puis il
ya un accompagnement financier qui n'est
pas négligeable pour une collectivité
territoriale
ces cent mille euros par an pendant deux
ans et donc nous allons les employés à
bon escient
évidemment mais en les flèches en
particulier sur les problématiques
d'accès à l'emploi et l'insertion le
site accueille aussi la mission locale
et le bureau information jeunesse à
carrières sous poissy 20% des moins de
25 ans sont actuellement sans emploi les
moins de 30 ans représentent 42 % de la
population